stand up David Carrick
[Music]
I've made ancillary orders for
deprivation pursuant to section 153 of
the sentencing Act 2020. and restraining
orders under sections 359 and 360 of the
ACT
they will remain in force until further
order
the victim's surcharge applies
I make no sexual harm prevention orders
given the nature of the sentence I'm
about to pass
on the main indictment on counts 16 19
29 30 31 32 38 39 42 and 43 the sentence
is four years imprisonment on each
concurrent
on counts 24 and 25 the sentence is
seven years on each concurrent
on count six on the second indictment I
impose a concurrent determinate sentence
of nine years
31 sentences of life imprisonment are
imposed on the main indictment on counts
one two three four
five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen Seventeen
eighteen twenty
22 23 26 27 28 33 34
40 and 41.
also five life sentences are imposed on
the second indictment on counts one two
three four and five
this makes a total of 36 life sentences
the minimum term you will have to serve
before the parole board can think of
releasing you is 30 years
239 days
and you may go down